lower levels of depression and
Improvement in quality of life just a
few of the benefits participants are
seeing thanks to a new free class to
help individuals locally with dementia
Dignity Health wellness centers offering
these new courses to help slow the
progression of the disease and those
suffering with mild to moderate dementia
[Music]
Cecil Patterson's husband George stopped
talking as much as he used to she knew
something was very wrong doctor
confirmed that his memory is getting
worse bad a mild case of dementia more
than 55 million people live with
dementia worldwide nearly 10 million new
cases are diagnosed every year
but a new course offered at Dignity
Health called CST cognitive stimulation
therapy has shown to offer patients more
positive interactions with their family
less dependence on others and the
ability to maintain their independence
the studies show that participants in
CST are slowing their disease process at
a similar rate as people who take
pharmaceutical medications to slow the
dementia disease progress
the course is one hour twice a week for
seven weeks it promotes cognitive
function through conversation
socialization and physical activity with
activities for concentration and memory
as well we tried it for two weeks and he
said you know what I really like doing
this you know I'm you know I'm he's
happy to get up and get dressed and you
know come out what we were both very
excited about was we have a series of
questions for orientation that we asked
at the beginning of each class to to see
where they're at cognitively and they
all nailed it with confidence today the
program I can't say enough about it
because it's it's helping it's helping
him it's helping me
and there is another round of classes
beginning the first part of October call
the number on your screen
702-616-4922 for more information and to
register Dignity Health Wellness Center
free courses starting up again next
month